tony blair's former director of
communications will publish his fifth
volume this one beginning with his
departure from Downing Street he joins
me now very good to see you and I
mentioned there's a number of memoirs
silora they signed out but they're all
very recent you know we're all talking
about brexit there's three or four
around at the moment I mean yours from
2003 to five seem an awful long time ago
well I was actually looking through the
index yesterday Jeremy Corbyn is not in
at all Theresa Mayes in it once and it's
got nothing is essentially about
something she says about David Miliband
if you just if I just said in the intro
you know back then by the time they're
published well yeah coming out of the
European Union Corbin will be Labour
leader David Cameron all have been and
gone suppose Cameron's not really in it
much the general election yes it comes
in a little bit but I think you are you
know you're deaf and also it starts with
the Hutton Inquiry so Iraq still very
much a big part of it and goes up to the
election Tony Gordon is like a big big
thing going on the whole time so it's
yeah it does feel like quite a long time
ago but there's a lot of you in there I
mean it's very personal as well as they
all are but you know about your
depression and about then he things have
changed you've officially left Tony
Blair's side but you're like a moth to
the flame you can't seem to get away I
mean day one this is the interesting
thing by keeping a diary when you go
back and transcribe it so I left as you
remember and quite a you know kerfuffle
going on during the Hutton Inquiry day
one Tony actually not only asked me to
go and see him he asked me to go to Iraq
as like his man in Iraq and I didn't
even tell Fiona about that one because
that was like your wife know no chance
whatsoever but then thereafter it's true
I was getting and there's a tension in
there the whole time I'm trying to start
a new life I'm trying to get out but I'm
getting brought back in the whole time
and I still have that a sense is still a
part of me that wants to kind of you
know he's scream at politics and
what-have-you but you've just got a you
know I think I've got to accept that was
my time and things have moved on and did
you get paid for it and you got to eat
no no I listen I wasn't sure but the III
did get paid during the election
campaign I went back and our novela yeah
he said listen if you're gonna do a
proper role we should pay you but no
generally I didn't know everyone's
drawing parallels now with with braixen
I mentioned all the memoirs coming out
about that at the moment but you know
reading through those Diaries that the
straws and more are in the wind there
and do you have a view on this this
central charge and it was used during
the referendum campaign by the relief
side that's a labor of those years made
a deliberate attempt to open up the UK
to mass migration to rub the Wrights
nose in diversity no it wasn't that
wasn't it wasn't about rubbing the
Wrights nose in it at all but I do think
that there was always this tension
between knowing that the economy and
public service is needed immigration and
also Tony did really believe in the kind
of the European vision if you like and I
think what you're right what comes
through in the Diaries is a sense that
we're we're spotting a problem but we're
really struggling with solution but he
wasn't wing you up Tony Blair was
running that wasn't he was panicking
going into that election campaign with
2005 one of the key planks that the
conservative was the main and when it
was asylum seekers and refugees there
and they were and it was asylum seekers
and refugees and the way that they were
making that about public services and
the pressure on public services the way
the country was changing and I think
it's possible to make the argument that
because we won in 2001 and 2005 where
the Tories really were hitting us hard
on immigration then maybe we got a
little bit complacent because we did win
we won again even though Michael Howard
really didn't make that a big part of
his campaign so I think I think you're
right that there are I think there are
all sorts of seeds in there for what I
see now I mean Tony you know he
definitely believed that he could
persuade the public genuinely and
finally to accept Britain's place in the
heart of Europe now it's obvious from
what's happening today that we that that
was not achieved likewise I think in
relation to immigration I think he felt
and I felt that we could we could
persuade people that yes there's a
downside to this but the upside is
bigger and again if you look at what's
happened in recent years suggest that
that has failed as well so I think there
I think that look I think Tony was a
great Prime Minister I think New Labour
was a great political force and we did a
lot of good things but I think you can
see the sea side the Seas but but
there's one crucial structural decision
taken there and whether it was right or
wrong that's 2004 the accession of the
so-called yes Eastern eight and
transitional controls were offered to
the UK seven years before they can come
in there and your own assessment said
well the Germans are taking those
transitional controls yeah so many
obviously the biggest labor market in
the European Union and right next door
to Poland of course but many of those
Polish people will therefore come to the
UK and once they've settled then their
friends relatives brothers then then
they'll come over here what I want those
transitional controls taken I think we
because of a belief that actually it was
going to benefit the economy and I think
that look I can see why looking back
people think we didn't have the eye on
the ball but you know this this is the I
think important thing about Diaries is
there's no kind of hindsight in there
it's it's really about the decisions
that have been made then and I do think
that there was a sense that we were the
country was moving the country was
changing it was it was going in a
direction that we thought would actually
be able to deal with this and you know
you look at where we are today and you
can you can have an argument about that
for sure
well they argue I mean want to throw at
you looking at it today I've you know
just come back I'm sure you were keeping
your clothes home and it's on there on
the Labor Party conference in in
Liverpool Jeremy Corbyn speech they're
basically saying well you know
immigration is not a problem it has less
labor got it you know we will put in
money into communities affected but it's
not a problem you've got to understand
this lot of labour voters don't believe
that I mean I I actually think in terms
of the principle under underlying his
approach on immigration is if you like
the right one that we should have been
arguing for a very very long time I
think coming as it does in this current
political context I think it's dangerous
politically for him to to do that but
you know I thats the other thing that's
really interesting about you know to
look back that into 2003 2005 the period
the diaries and now Jeremy Corbyn as
leader again a thing what a big part of
the narrative is this kind of Tony
Gordon thing going on so big and so bad
if you like that we just didn't develop
the talent and when it came to it first
ed then Jeremy we're out of time
Alastair good see thank you very much
see ya later